okay so I have something really
interesting for us to take a look at
today I already told you earlier one of
the most important polls historically in
primary elections is the Des Moines
Register poll of Iowa voters shortly
before the Iowa caucus that poll came
out a few days ago it is shortly before
the Iowa caucuses we already analyzed
the poll itself
Bernie Sanders is leading by several
points I already told you this is
important Iowa's not the be-all end-all
the polling could change between now and
the day that I Owens go to the caucuses
but the there is no question whatsoever
that winning the Iowa caucus would be a
huge boost of momentum for whoever wins
it and this is a really big deal for
Bernie Sanders particularly since he's a
candidate that was blacked out by
corporate media for a long time
ignored made a foregone conclusion that
he simply cannot win and corporate media
is in disarray over how to cover
Bernie's surge and Bernie's lead in Iowa
and they are doing trapeze artistry to
get around and underneath and over the
reality that Bernie's just doing well
and he may win the Iowa caucus and then
he will be in contention for the
Democratic nomination doesn't mean South
Carolina is going to go his way I know
it's popular right away to point out why
Iowa is so white as soon as it gets the
South Carolina Bernie screwed maybe okay
but we're talking about Iowa right now I
have examples for you from MSNBC and
from CNN let's start with the Democratic
centrist establishment channel MSNBC
which said headline Iowa poll questioned
by experts that's the headline not
Bernie surges to lead in Iowa poll it's
Iowa poll questioned by expert here's
the video associated with that story
Joann Reid interviewing Jimmy Williams
to say can we trust this poll yeah I
guess we can but the poll can still
change doing everything possible to
essentially say let's just not really
believe that Bernie is truly in the lead
in Iowa take a look I am perplexed by
this poll for two reasons first either
the people of Iowa are schizophrenic or
they just aren't convinced they remain
skeptical yeah I mean you've done
think the people of Iowa are
schizophrenic although they do have two
horrifying GOP senators as their
senators but that's a separate
conversation for a separate day this
poll is not an outlier this is in fact
as Fran said the gold standard this is
it when it came out last night at seven
o'clock or whatever time it came out
Eastern Time I looked at it went no way
in hell is this right but it has to be
right because this Des Moines right hand
the more register and see it in and so I
mean I just don't see this I think a lot
can change between now and the day of
those caucuses and I done these numbers
they tell me something at 30,000 feet
they tell me nothing on the ground in
Des Moines or Dubuque or anywhere else
that's my takeaway from so he knows he
can't really say it's not accurate
because this is a known very solid poll
so it's more well okay maybe maybe we
can't say it's not accurate but this can
change and we're three weeks out and
whatever then in comes CNN remember this
is a Des Moines Register CNN joint poll
CNN's on-screen graphic chooses to say
now that bernie is winning the headline
is no clear leader it's so predictable
of course the results Bernie twenty
Warren seventeen Budaj edge sixteen and
Biden 15 the headline no clear leader
and you know it it's technically sort of
true the margin of error is 3.7 bernie
is up by three but when it was Biden up
by three the headlines weren't no clear
leader the headlines were Biden's
winning in Iowa when it was Budaj edge
that took a lead in Iowa the headlines
were not no clear leader it was Budaj
edge surges from behind to take a lead
lead in Iowa so this is not you know an
unhinged Bernie's obviously going to win
and everyone's wrong and it's a
conspiracy this is yet again the
different way in which corporate media
will frame a poll depending on whether
an establishment candidate is winning or
a progressive candidate is winning the
margin of error in polls in Iowa has
been between three and four for months
that's not new so why is the margin of
error
now relevant for saying the headline is
no clear winner when when it was a
different candidate the margin of error
did not play into the headlines that
were chosen by corporate media and again
I already gave these disclaimers earlier
winning Iowa is not the be all end all
you need voters that are very different
from Iowa voters to win the Democratic
nomination
Bernie may not have them or he might
Iowa is not going to tell us that it is
a closed poll but if you look at the
trend line of Iowa polling you see that
Bernie Sanders bottomed out in Iowa in
mid to late September and he's been up
up up since then while Biden is down
Budaj edge popped up but now is back
down Warren is down from where she was
and now the headline that bernie is
winning is no clear leader when it was
always Biden ahead boo to judge ahead
Warren surging so let's wait and see
this is one primary at a time but the
lesson is don't accept corporate media's
characterization of a poll just look at
the poll yourself look at the trend
lines yourself look at the polling data
and the methodology yourself and be
comfortable coming up with the analysis
yourself there's too much riding on this
and it's too important to be led by
these incorrect narratives and summaries
of polls that someone is choosing to do
do the work to check it out for yourself
and we will all be far better off and
that gets us now to Donald Trump
realizing he may he may have to face
Bernie Sanders in the general election I
know that the David Pakman show audience
is full of curious and creative people
who love learning new things and
bettering themselves and that's why I'm
so excited to tell you about one of our
sponsors Skillshare the vibrant online
learning community that offers thousands
of classes on almost any topic you can
imagine and you'll get full access to
the entire library of classes for two
entire months free when you go to david
pakman.com slash skill all of the
classes are taught by experts in their
fields they've got classes on drawing
painting photography video editing web
design bookkeeping marketing personal
productivity doesn't even scratch the
surface I recently took a class about
photography if anybody follows me on
Instagram you know that my photography
skills leave much to be desired and it
was great I got so much out of it and
hopefully you will see the fruit
of me taking that class reflected in my
Instagram pictures sooner than later
they have classes for every skill level
whether you're wanting to get better at
something you already have experience
with you want to learn something totally
new to you you set your own pace classes
are usually less than an hour long
they're divided up into bite-size
segments so you can easily fit them into
your schedule make 2020 a year where you
explore new skills deep in existing
passions get lost in creativity
Skillshare really makes it easier than
ever
Skillshare memberships are less than ten
bucks a month and that gives you access
to the thousands of classes they offer
but everybody in the David Pakman show
audience gets a Skillshare membership
totally free for two whole months just
go to david pakman.com slash skill
that's david pakman.com slash s ki ll